hey I have you heard about this Hamilton
thing at this this is one of my favorite
stories up post Donald's election Donald
Trump ran his campaign on a few memes
one being he's against political
correctness right Rumpel use whatever
words he wants people who get offended
or silly freedom of speech no safe
spaces no trigger warnings the all right
love Trump and it's all fantastic except
now after a message was directed at vice
president-elect Mike Pence when he went
to the musical Hamilton in New York City
Donald Trump lashed out on Twitter
calling for the theater to be a safe
space literally using those words so the
back story is pence goes to the super
popular musical Hamilton in manhattan
new york city over the weekend first of
all tons of people booed and jeered as
Mike Pence walked in Manhattan a super
liberal Mike Pence is not a Manhattan
guy the crowd booed which has nothing to
do with how pence was treated by the
people putting on the show pence was
addressed by the cast of Hamilton and
Donald Trump went on Twitter calling it
harassment okay here's a tweet that
Donald Trump put out our wonderful
future VP mike pence was harassed last
night at the theater by the cast of
Hamilton cameras blazing this should not
happen what was the horrible harassment
that Mike Pence had to endure well we
have video of it let's take a look
prepare yourselves for harassment ladies
and gentlemen vice president Mike Pence
we welcome you and we truly good for
Jonah is here Hamilton attorney really
do we sir we are the diverse America who
are a lot and anxious that your new
administration will not protect us our
parents or defend us and uphold our
inalienable rights sir but we truly look
at this show has inspired to a model our
American
and to work on the Hat all wow they
really disrespected pens huh thanking
him for showing up respectfully
expressing a concern about his upcoming
administration and hoping that the play
served in it is as an inspiration Trump
is the most thin-skinned buffoon that we
will ever have had as president that I
can recall and actor Brandon Victor
Dixon responded by saying Trump is
flat-out wrong he actually tweeted
Donald Trump conversation is not
harassment sir and I appreciate mike
pence for stopping to listen and then
here's the clincher sit down okay get
the kids out of the room because this
double standard might knock them down
here is the clincher Trump tweeted that
theaters must be safe spaces quote the
theater must always be a safe and
special place safe and special place
everything Pat in Trump's campaign has
been the opposite game building support
for being the anti safe space guy when
it comes to terms like radical Islam
when it comes to calling Mexicans
rapists when it comes to making fun of
disabled reporters or women no safe
spaces because this is the real world
until a respectful message is made to
Mike Pence in a theater whoa whoa whoa
we need safe spaces now right i mean the
irony doesn't even work anymore can we
just expect Donald Trump to contradict
himself yeah and this is fundamentally
authoritarian right Trump gets to
dictate which are the safe spaces and
which are the places where it's okay to
make fun of whatever group you don't
like could this guy be more of a baby
the Hamilton Hamilton castus thank you
and you will be our president and our
vice president and here's a concern we
have and Trump runs to Twitter to
literally demand the institution of safe
spaces the problem is Trump space which
has been supporting him for a year or
more at this point will see this as
confirmation that liberals are
intolerant or something the this guy is
the biggest joke we have seen in
national politics period gamefly is sort
of like Netflix for video games they
have over 8,000 new and classic games
for xbox one Xbox
360 ps4 ps3 wii and a bunch of other
platforms and you can play as many games
as you want for one monthly fee and if
you find some games you want to keep you
can buy them for a low used price
there's never any due dates or late fees
and our audience can get a free 30-day
trial at gamefly offer.com / TDPS the
games are shipped directly to you with
return envelopes included there's no
contracts and you can rent games through
the mobile app get the free 30-day trial
for the david pakman show audience and
support our show by going to gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s